voilà, est-ce que ça ressemble
clairement au corps d'un combattant, je m'en fous non
[Musique] [
Musique]
façon ouais je l'aime bien comme Titan Fury
étranger
[Musique]
a dit non, ce ne sera pas un bon nom pour
lui parce qu'il va seulement être petit à quel point
il avait tort
[Musique]
étranger [
Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
boxeur à l'époque dans les années 80 et au
début des années 90
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a gagné alors qu'est-ce que tu vas dire  ce
type est toujours un clochard, il a battu le plus grand
combattant des 15 dernières années
[Musique] [
Musique]
ils sont tous ensemble maintenant alors au revoir mademoiselle
American Pie J'ai conduit ma Chevrolet jusqu'à la
digue mais la digue était sèche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements  ]
bien à
chaque fois que j'allais à la piscine mais pas 10
livres de bière et je pensais que oui, je voulais me
battre ce soir
[Musique]
et c'est vraiment Deontay Wilder qui
m'a encouragé et m'a donné l'ambition
de revenir parce qu'il  a dit que je ne pouvais pas
le faire il a dit que ce n'était absolument pas Tyson Fury c'est
Don et je marchais le long du canal
avec mon chien au moment où
je vais tomber tu sais ce que je suis un gros
cochon regarde et dis-moi j'avais envie
J'ai sauté dans l'eau et je l'ai noyé et
euh, je pensais que j'allais inverser la tendance
et je dois revenir et je
vais l'assommer
[Musique] [
Musique]
Je suis le meilleur combattant de mon  Je suis un
combattant de génération. En fait, je suis désolé
pour tous ces gars qui commencent à me combattre à
l'étranger
[Musique]
mais je veux juste y retourner et
danser sous les étoiles comme je n'arrête pas de le dire.